Oh Pacey good news Oh Elsa I don't care
why are you calling mom Elsa your
Clayton uniform came today it is
adorable it just looks smart what do you
think of the roast I tried a new
prepackaged spice mix cheater for most
mammalian species survival depends on
knowing and sticking with your pack stop
sitting on me like an egg I'm not an egg
but the members of my pack keep
migrating to other schools I hate it
there
just give it a chance hey I'm Casey
don't care to other houses you threw a
grenade into our lives I can't be around
you or just away from me it's a mystery
what was once something that seems so
rock solid it cracks wide open before
you know it you are so deep it's
impossible to dig yourself back out if
anyone find it difficult to deal with
change but there's always a way out
I know it's gonna be difficult but you
can handle it he hasn't applied to any
colleges I have no idea what I should do
you have to start making decisions for
yourself what do you want to do
everybody has setbacks oh you can't let
em bring you down would you feed this
out okay
I used my discount to get you these
pencils for school you don't have to do
that I'll be a big brother I can take
care of you sometimes too
[Music]
they must look like terrible parents
really you seem like people
it's a rough world out there that's why
you need your family
I like that we're secure enough to do
this semi-regularly I'm neutral about it
[Music]